Hello world.
Welcome this around geology.
I met the base impact hackathon in San Francisco.
Okay.
There's a lot of great sponsors and partners that made this entire event
possible.
Thank you.
Sponsor
crazy.
That guy.
I Dunno.
So what were you saying though?
Or are you saying though?
Well maybe you find that you maybe find new particle into data being read in
really cool in a certain data and certain data or if you could,
if you could prove supersymmetry or not look disprove supersymmetry that's what
people are looking for.
Maybe you'll find new physics.
So it would be reading for new physics would be awesome.
You should go for it.
Yeah,
you are.
You cause you,
you studied that stuff,
right?
What,
what kind of physics do you do?
I do theoretical,
solid state physics,
specifically quantum computing.
Okay.
Could you introduce yourself just in general?
In general.
All right.
My name is [inaudible].
Uh,
I'm a physicist with a background in economics and from Germany currently
working at UC Berkeley.
And uh,
today we've got to do some data magic.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
what,
what got you interested in machine learning?
I think machines are gonna take over the future and want to be part of it.
Awesome.
And Are you excited for this hackathon?
How are you feeling?
I feel kind of tired to be very honest,
but I'm very happy because we found a really cool rule and their love drawing on
whiteboards.
One interesting fact and then why you're here today.
Sure.
When did you see back in June?
I'm biking from Vancouver to Allana and uh,
why am here today?
Uh,
I think that is impact's mission is pretty,
uh,
just exciting.
Um,
especially in silicon valley where I think like a lot of people are solving.
I'm kind of like not as as fundamentally important problems Matt.
Um,
for me I've always been interested in the data science for social good space.
I used to work in data science in the healthcare space.
For me,
an interesting fact,
I'm half Filipino.
Okay.
I want to work on this because,
uh,
I feel like when we are technology workers,
we've put a lot of energy behind making technology,
but I'm a little concerned that policy might not catch up.
So I really want to put a lot of energy behind that as well.
I feel this is very solution oriented.
Like this is like the output is very late.
You can grasp it.
It's like this is what we have,
this what we can do,
this is what you should do.
It kind of is like,
so from them,
from a data science perspective,
what,
what are we trying to do?
Like what,
okay,
so we have all this,
how do we figure out,
uh,
what you suggest to people?
Is it just based on what other people have chosen or,
um,
so that's one way to do recommender system,
right?
Well that depends on what kind of,
Oh yeah,
we got the good stuff.
We got the good stuff.
Tobias,
are you excited to eat?
Are you excited to buy us such excited?
Wow.
Yeah,
maybe you're just
popular.
I feel like it shows your industry growth.
Average wage.
These are like recommended jobs and yeah,
you can search and it's just going to slice the data in the query and it goes on
similar jobs.
You don't think me a monster page.
Hi Guys.
It's midnight.
It's time for me to leave the hackathon.
Check it out.
A lot of people here,
you guys are just woke up.
Uh,
it's 90 of the next day.
I'm heading back and judging ceremonies happening.
Let's go see what happens.
Very similar.
Okay,
great.
It's all good.
It's been a long,
how are you feeling?
Faith
is not working.
Pre Demo balloons.
We don't chat internally.
We have the wheel of death
complaints.
Referee,
the referee,
uh,
has,
sexy tech intentionally a novelists fraud or a malicious behavior that's
targeting certain groups.